good morning billion nation I'm Evan
Carmichael my warn word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the world's major problem I
started to believe life series to try to
step outside just the world of
entrepreneurship and learn from
different areas to try to help us become
better more well-rounded individuals who
go out and have a big impact so in
today's episode we're going to learn how
you can travel the world rule number one
is my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the best
and as always guys you're watching if
someone says something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
in the comments below a book quote
ceramics or other people can be inspired
and when you write it down for yourself
it's much more likely to stick for you
as well
enjoy
[Music]
what is it about new places that
attracts us to them we first wander
explore and discover
what drives us to fly around the world
to touch a wall
find our life
in their dislike
in our veins is human nature
it drives farther
since I hired
that shows a family on and breaks of
free
Oh
[Music]
once you touch the world you change
yours forever
[Music]
it's a craving that exists in all of us
would you leave you with only one option
take a place
five till I booked a one-way ticket to
Thailand sleep this pack a bag
make a plan in the go again
[Music]
yes
[Music]
if you have a dream if you have this
crazy idea you must believe in it
even if no one else does so when I had
the idea to go to every country in the
world that's kind of what it felt like
it felt like this crazy idea it was like
that just sounds like totally ridiculous
and absurd but I couldn't stop thinking
about it
and I realized that if I didn't pursue
it I would always regret it
and that knowledge that fear of regret
kind of drove me to say yes and I talked
to lots of other people who use very
similar language there's a guy from
Portland Maine whose crazy idea was to
walk across America and he wasn't even
sure like how does that work how much
time does it take has anyone done this
before
it was this crazy idea that wouldn't
leave him alone and so one morning he
left his home in Maine and he started
walking and seven and a half months
later he arrived in San Francisco and I
talked to him throughout the whole
journey I talked him in the beginning
and in the middle in the end I asked him
you know what was the what were the
challenges like and how did it go and he
said he said something that stayed with
me for the rest of my journey he said
you know there were lots of external
challenges it was hard on the body to
get used to walking that much lots of
things went wrong there were some
emotional challenges as well he had just
had a breakup and he was kind of
processing all of this he said but what
I realized about two weeks in once I
started complaining once I stopped
complaining and grumbling about the
whole thing he said I realized that my
task was pretty simple all I had to do
was walk essentially and if I did
nothing else if I got up every morning
and I made a little bit of progress then
eventually I would reach the goal
eventually I would arrive in San
Francisco and you know achieved that
goal reach that destination and it
sounded really simple but it kind of
stayed with me for the you know the
final two years of my quest because
that's how I felt it was for me too all
I had to do was get to 193 countries and
I had my list of countries and I was
making progress and if I got somewhat
stuck somewhere you know eventually I'd
have to overcome that challenge but I
could go and do some others first and I
liked the logical analytical progress of
it it's something that related to me so
just
going you have to believe in your dream
even if no one else does let me give you
the basics of what I personally did to
travel for nearly three months
financially speaking first I picked my
destination and bought my plane ticket
in this particular case it was actually
cheaper for me to buy a one-way ticket
to New York City and then a one-way
ticket from New York to Berlin with a
stopover in Oslo then it was for me to
buy a one-way ticket directly from Las
Vegas to Berlin with any stopovers so
although it added a little bit of time
to my itinerary I saved a couple hundred
dollars my favorite web site for buying
tickets is google.com slash flight
because it shows you both on a map and
in calendar format the specific days as
well as the airports it would be
cheapest to fly into if you're somebody
who always goes for the cheapest flights
this is the best tool that I have
personally found and if you're the more
adventurous type with no specific
destination in mind sky scanner comm is
a fantastic option simply because they
literally have the option to search for
anywhere on the globe so for example
let's say that you are available at some
point during the month of March but you
don't know when yet and you're available
to go anywhere but you don't know where
you want to go on Skyscanner you can
literally select an entire month that
you would want to travel at some point
during and you can actually select the
everywhere option when you're searching
for a destination so doing it this way
will show you the keepest place to fly
on the planet during the entire month of
March to travel to from your specific
destinations so if you're the
adventurous type I highly recommend it's
fantastic once I bought my plane tickets
I researched a little bit of what I
wanted to do in the specific countries I
was going to for me I personally love
museums learning about history and the
occasional nice meal I also knew that I
would be traveling by train between
countries and I would be staying
primarily in hostels so I pretty much
just googled a little bit of what I
wanted to do in each country got a price
range for those specific activities
added it up and multiplied it by the
number of days I would be traveling this
was my basic budget due to the fact that
I'd be traveling through Europe during
the high season it can get expensive so
just to be safe
I upped my daily budget to $100
a day yes this is a lot of money no you
don't need to do this I ended up
spending on average way under $100 a day
but it was comforting knowing that I had
a little extra wiggle room in my budget
in case anything came up I highly
recommend giving yourself a daily budget
no matter what it is during the entire
time that you're traveling a daily
budget and my personal opinion is a lot
easier to keep in the back of your head
than an overarching budget that spans
for weeks and weeks and weeks on end
for water when we went to Central
America or Asia we used to buy a lot of
bottled water and we felt really bad
about it it was a lot of plastic and it
was actually really expensive so now we
got ourselves a really small portable
water purifier this one's a SteriPEN
it's you can charge it with USB and it
works really well it's just a altra
violet light that kills the bacteria and
we basically just fill up our water
bottle with water you turn it on put it
in a year and stir it for about a minute
and your water is clean and ready to
drink for food and snacks we usually try
to bring our own stuff because food at
the airport and the train station and
basically any touristy area is usually
overpriced and really expensive so we'll
usually pack a bag of our own snacks so
that we can save money and also make
sure that we have the food that we
actually like to eat it's important to
check out the different guidelines for
where you're going because they're
always changing and often you can't
bring things like produce liquids raw
nuts and things like that packing our
food is also a great way to make sure
that we're eating healthy food which we
can't always find when we're on the move
for staying clean we have a few really
simple things that we use and that work
really well for us one of our favorite
things is this laundry soap bar we use
this to wash our clothes by hand it is
nice to be independent and be able to do
that almost wherever you are and it
saves us a lot of money because we don't
have to go to laundromats another thing
we carry around with us is dry shampoo I
was very skeptical of this when Danielle
first talked about it but it actually
works really really well it's just a
little powder that you put in your hand
you mix it around in your hair and it's
like you washed your hair you kind of
get a little
refresher in between showers you can buy
this but you can also look it up and
make your own using pretty simple
ingredients like corn starch and another
thing that we bring with us almost all
the time and it helps us deal with those
days in between showers our wet wipes we
obviously don't bring a big container
like this but wet wipes combined with
the dry shampoo are a really great
simple portable way to stay clean on
lawns idle days and between showers and
lasts we always bring our trusty dr.
Bronner's soap this can be used for
anything it's natural its unscented so
we can wash dishes we can shower with
this so it's really really handy if
you're traveling outside the country
you're obviously going to need your
passport and you're going to need to
take really good care of it we got ours
stolen once and we just had one that it
was ruined by water damage and if
there's just a bit of water that smudges
the picture it's invalid so you got to
take really good care of it because if
something happens when you're in another
country then it's really expensive to
get a new one and it's a lot of trouble
so what we do now is that we always
carry it in a traveling pouch sometimes
in a pouch that we can hide on ourselves
and in that pouch we also keep the
passport in a ziplock bag it's really
simple it costs nothing and it'll save
it from getting water damage number four
work remotely these days certain jobs
can be done from anywhere whether its
programming to graphic design or
freelance writing and photography
websites like up work can help you find
work as a freelancer or hire other
freelancers to help you take your show
on the road the key is geo arbitrage
earning money and a strong currency and
spending it where it likes a little bit
cheaper think Southeast Asia a good
resource to learn more is Timothy
Ferriss 4-hour workweek seriously read
the book make sure you can make money
remotely if you can't
that's just not really fit in your me to
grasp the other very obvious option is
get a job somewhere else
whatever you doing at home somebody else
in the world somewhere else will have a
use for it it doesn't really matter you
can do that jobs for models granted you
might get paid less you could work in a
hostel where you'll get room and board
and some spending money and get hang out
with people and do cool - it's an
example right some examples of people
that we met were doing this lifestyle
living indefinitely where workers at
hospitals in Nicaragua we met a handful
of friends that have been there for
years like literally two three or five
years and that's all they do they live
on a beach they have this beautiful
lifestyle in paradise granted they don't
have a lot of the people luxuries that
you can call that we would add back home
they have a usually estimate you have
someone okay Wi-Fi you have our Mexican
meal not in Grandia you might not have a
house or car Leon you know you have a
bungalow on the beach and you have the
experience to rip around and you've got
coconuts and fried and you got hammocks
in the ocean but like that's some
people's vacation some people work
year-round to get two weeks of that well
I just you know set the switch alone
right I met a girl in Thailand who
essentially had been to 15 countries and
all she did was would go work at the
hostel for a month or so she'd make a
few hundred dollars that'd be enough to
take her to the next city the next
country she worked at actually work at a
bar so it's not difficult it's what
we're saying a lot of people do a lot of
very young people do it some people's
don't want to go to university they do
that to take our ocean a lot of people
are doing it and it's pretty simple and
I made all any friend of them he's kind
of with all this inspired you in some
way what we really want to get out of
this is to teach you and to help you
guys understand that travel is for
everyone you don't have to be rich to
travel no no
just to be smart we need to understand
the world of travel because you can do
it with a small amount of money you're
doing a huge way with a small amount of
money and you can do it forever if you
do it right you don't have to be rich to
travel actually all expenses while
you're travelling fall into three major
categories first the transportation to
get from point A to point B the other
thing is accommodation and the last is
everything else food drinks and so on if
you minimize those three expenses to
some minimum it can be actually cheaper
to travel than live in your own city for
the next five years I've been traveling
around the world with almost no money
and this is how I did it first thing I
hitchhike
apart from being free apart from being
really fast it allowed me one amazing
thing to have an adventure between point
A and point B how many of you guys have
a refuge hike maybe okay well quite a
lot why what are you doing okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna play you a short video
called hitchhiking guide just to tell
you a few unwritten rules about
hitchhiking and some of my experiences
when it comes to hitchhiking everything
is about using common sense
first starting up get us out friction as
just make things less number two stick
up your tongue problem also you have it
so striking lesson number 36
look detailed like save like where some
- we holds whatever or hide behind your
back Bible lesson for Forge do not
hitchhike during night
your choices which has two days to be
grumpy
lesson number 58 eye contact with the
drivers
little miracle
don't eat right below I have
the Iguana
lesson number 21 talk with the drivers
when you're in the car because that's
the only way you can be paid and they
would like to hear some interesting
stories if you have one yeah it's not
just listen to their story that's
sometimes you know let the number nine
that's the nearest 12 if you have one
in numbers
why or incomplete
we always have people cannot leave your
[ __ ] shaky it's your choice
don't explain
in symbols nothing will be wrong in
99.4% of cases but no matter how long
you wait the right driver column so that
annuity taking the ghoul so you have one
there are no road actually go guru
go out there enjoy life and challengers
thank you
we were real angry majora
Sebring
three two
when it comes to accommodation most of
the time I use couchsurfing because I
had a lot of experience that had a lot
of these positive references on the
website and so on and what I like about
couchsurfing the most is not only
because it's free it allows you to have
a different perspective of the
destination you're not destined to stay
in your hotel room or take the tourist
tours you just hang out with your host
he takes you on places that you would
probably never visit by yourself in rich
cities in rich countries I usually buy
food in supermarkets which is the
cheapest way and just eat on the street
you can also cook with your host which
can be pretty a pretty unique experience
to say the least
these are Germans actually sorry but it
was pretty delicious
to say the least then one of the
cheapest yeah one other thing when it
comes to traveling you can earn money
while the traveling how to do that I did
a couple of times one of them is busking
playing the guitar on the street I'm not
a musician I know like probably four or
five chords and four songs so it's like
repeat all you know like people are
passing by so they're like they don't
really know but the most the most
important thing is to have a story I
always had my small carbon board which I
wrote actually somebody else wrote in a
local language where I'm from what I'm
doing there what's my story and I think
that's what people donated a little bit
of money some sandwiches sodas and so on
you won't earn a lot of money by doing
this but it can get you through the day
one other way is to write you can write
a blog
open up a Facebook page after after a
while you can maybe write a book and so
on is it for everyone this type of
traveling I don't think so
with all the amazing things that this
kind of traveling can bring to you there
are also downsides it's a big chance
that you will be lonely that you will be
hungry
the two will be sick but you will be
homesick but it all comes down to your
gut feeling if after all these ideas and
all the acknowledges you still have that
Wow
I wish I could travel like this then you
should definitely do it then you should
forget about your fears disregard the
fact that you're broke and just leave
head to the road because like that
famous quote says in 20 years from now
on you will be more disappointed by the
things you didn't do than by the things
you did
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think of this
video what was the biggest takeaway that
you're going to immediately apply
somehow in your life or maybe your
business let me know leave it down the
comments below really curious to find
out I also want to give a quick shout
out to Wesley lavender from fully
optimized org
Wesley thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word and
offering to do a review on it I really
appreciate this department and I'm glad
you're enjoying the week so thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
have an amazing day I believe in you
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
we all have these like great ideas right
and at the same time we have
responsibilities and mortgages and you
know whatever so I guess I'm just
wondering what your advice is so people
who you know want to go out and pursue
certain things but they're also like
certain limitations I guess that we have
to like exist within I mean I guess we
don't but you know I can't walk away
from my condo tomorrow and walk across
the country probably wouldn't work out
well for me but yeah that's a great
question but do you want to walk across
the country like is that your aspiration
right this is it so I'm a big fan of
defining our aspirations and then
crafting our life around them
essentially you know and so like the
quest to visit every country in the
world for example I was thinking about
this the other day
and the first 100 countries cost about
thirty thousand dollars so thirty
thousand at least I would argue is not a
huge amount of money for going to 100
countries and all the life experience
that I got through that and also I
didn't have to pay it all right away you
pay-as-you-go essentially in something
like that so you know these these
limitations as you said maybe that's not
called a limitation and their
responsibilities especially people with
families like you don't just leave your
family and walk across the country but
again there are ways to cultivate the
value of adventure that's why I like the
story of Sasha and what she did at home
there's a woman in Omaha who's knitting
10,000 hats and her passion thing that
she really loved was always knitting and
one Christmas time or holiday time she
was she made a hundred hats for her
friends and family and she was like
that's really fun I want to do a
thousand but a thousand is not a big
enough challenge so she took on this
goal of ten thousand hats and there's a
charity component to it you can connect
with her on her website and can
eventually get a hat so I mean I don't
know responsibilities and things are
real but if something matters to us I
guess I'm also a believer in figuring
out how to how to do that right like we
do have to trade off things we do have
to sacrifice and and especially for all
of us with so many opportunities
available to us it's a matter of
prioritization you know it's a matter of
you know I can probably do anything I
want but I can't do everything right so
if I if this thing really does matter to
me whether it's walking across the
country or whatever it is in your case
and then it's something that you have to
plan for and built for and for me it was
it was worth it to do that I have a
small story short story about these
prejudices that I encountered while I
was traveling when I was leaving
Croatian heading on my round-the-world
trip everybody was telling me be careful
it's very dangerous you know you're
going to hitchhike you're going to sleep
in other people's homes and stuff like
that
in Croatia I still okay to travel you
know but as soon as you cross the border
entry into Serbia
you know what Serbians are like you know
be very very careful somebody might kill
you and I'm like okay thank you for the
warning and I crossed the border enter
into Serbia amazing adventures amazing
people I met people picking me up taking
me out sleeping in their homes really
really amazing experiences and I was
reading serve they're heading to
Bulgaria
I was driving with one driver and
telling him that story like how
creations were warning me about Serbians
and he's like ah brother you know that's
complete nonsense Croatians and Serbians
world brothers but Bulgarians oh when
you cross the border enter into Bulgaria
you know what Bulgarians are like a lot
of gypsies man you know
be very careful somebody might kill you
and enter Bulgaria the same story all
over again amazing experiences people
were just extremely friendly and then I
was driving with one truck driver going
towards Turkey and I was telling him the
same story like how creation bournemouth
about Serbian Serbian is about
Bulgarians and he's like a brother you
know that complete nonsense they are
Croatian Serbian Bulgarians little
Balkan brothers but Turkish people oh my
god you know what Turkish are people are
like you know very dangerous somebody
might kill you Turkish Turkish people
warned me about Kurdish people Kurdish
people about the Iran is Iran is about
Pakistanis Pakistanis about Indians
Indians didn't warn about anything
anyone are
so I get a last frontier or something
beats me ah but yeah it wasn't hungry
you want to know the travel lesson but
maybe a life lesson like not to trust
all these horror stories people were
telling me and my last couple most
obscure tip is changing your
relationship with money I'm gonna be a
little bit harsher it's the biggest
problem in your life right now is saving
money to travel you are pretty damn
lucky think about all of the other
problems you could be having in your
life family problems health problems not
having enough money to put food on the
table problem those are actual
legitimate problems being bummed because
you can't travel is a pretty awesome
problem to have and once you start
seeing it as a privilege to have that
problem as opposed to this crippling
reason of why you can't travel you can
start simplifying money in your life and
figuring out ways to get what you want
if you want a big money to travel you
have two options spend less or make more
we talked about how to figure out what
your overhead is and your take-home so
start looking through things that you
cut out of your daily life so you can
save more to travel and if you don't
want to cut out going out with your
friends and drinking lattes and mouth
fine but that just means now you need to
make more money can you pick up another
job when I realized that I wanted to be
able to quit my job to travel the world
I need to save up a lot of money really
quick and I knew that there was no Air
India yet with my current job as surf
instructor so I think it's a bartending
job at night and then I think that the
job being brand ambassador for a natural
soap company on the weekend I was
working all the time not only that but
then I started cutting back on all of my
daily expenses I'm moving to a cheaper
apartment I stopped drinking and eating
out I did absolutely everything I could
to minimize my overhead and maximize my
take home if your dream is to travel
then that's the way you can do it too